le livre de jean michel maire fait
polémique jean michel vous avez annoncé
il ya quelques temps être en train
d'écrire un livre sur la séduction qui
devrait sortir en juin mais le
descriptif de ce fameux livre est sorti
dans la presse et ça fait déjà beaucoup
parler
je vais vous lire le pitch du livre de
jean michel maire jean michel maire nous
révèle enfin tous ces trucs et astuces
pour devenir un expert de la drague
après des années d'observations
intensifs de la gente féminine davanture
chaotique et sans lendemain de
ratatouille de nuit d'amour cocasses ou
démon des astuces à découvrir et à
tester les dix commandements du lover
l'alphabet zh le lexique du dragueur ça
promet les techniques du dragueur pour
sauver n'importe quelle situation fois
reçu des jeux le cdh au que tu sais pas
il va dans le jeu de sudoku pour se
détendre après l'amour des jeux de rôles
à l'endroit et à l'envers
mais ni de folie les lendemains de fêtes
ou l'art de l'esquivé
la success story town of thrones le vrai
livre d'or michel mr une chose est sûre
c'est que pour l'instant ce livre n'est
pas du goût de tout le monde
alors est ce que vous aimez ou vous est
ce que vous n'aimez pas l'idée que jean
michel mr écrive un livre sur la
séduction parce que ça a pris une
tournure très sérieux c'est pour ça que
vous vous en parler soit sur twitter
beaucoup de féministes on vous ont
reproché l'audace d'écrire un livre sur
la séduction en faisant écho à l'extrême
vous embrassiez la poitrine de soria en
2016 vous vous êtes longuement expliqué
là-dessus
et voilà donc il ya des gens qui jean
michel maire va sortir un livre
gentleman lover comment draguer sans
importuner
pour mémoire c'est lui qui m'a embrassé
sur le sur le st une femme qui refusait
de l'embrasser sur le gâteau de tpm pay
pay tâche nec a dit comment repousser
quel moment les limites de l'indécence
clarence edgar et voilà qu'une idée
qu'elle est bonne gentleman autoproclamé
proclamé sur le 7 juin guide pour
draguer sont importunés
chic on y apprendra peut-être embrasser
contre leur gré des invités ont planté
pmp mais avec respect 1
il ya un journaliste gabier assouline
qui travaille pour le huffington post
qui vous a mis un petit taquet aussi en
écrivant un article qui dénoncent le
fait qu'une personne comme vous puisse
apprendre à draguer et c'est pas le
dernier non plus voilà où mènent des
attaques et il y en a plein voilà je
vous le dis
voilà avant lui nous les détails est
tout le temps en plus un gars est à
souligner c'est pas la croix rouge
compte il vous aime pas voilà non mais
tout le temps à chaque fois il nous fait
des articles voilà il est des limites
des conneries voile en plus ils y ont
tué des conneries donc garder assouline
voilà donc il vous a mis encore une
interview à laquelle j'ai très gentiment
répondu que c était à l'heure du dîner
ne pouvait pas répondre à ce moment là
mais que demain le langage s'appellerait
donc aujourd'hui mais j'ai pas eu le
temps de le rappeler parce que l'article
et sortiront ils répondront qu'ils
assurent si je pense hélas sans savoir
s'il a écrit sans savoir ce que vous
allez faire une certaine aussi nadia
daam une journaliste pour le site slate
mais qui officie sur europe 1 et 28
minutes sur arte qui vous a critiqué
également rien ne nous sera donc épargné
mais je vous rassure jean mis aussi l
beaux-arts cas vous ait fait ou fera
casse à chaque fois que les gens qui
vous fracassez et il nous fera qu'à ses
yeux des gens qui nous fera ce que je
vois les gens venant concernant ces deux
jours nadia daam week-end sur 28 lignes
ou à vous poser qui vous concerne par
rapport au livre femmes mariées 28
minutes
oui sur sur le niveau sur europe 1 sur
28 minutes sur 28 minutes sur nadia daam
ça c'était d'un vrai j'aurais pu vous
posez là non c'est non mais vraiment
tout puisque c'est tous les opposants
c'est que c'est pas à nous c'est pas une
bonne et son sérieux 28 minutes et et et
non où on apporte aux leurs mais alors
vous aimez le livre de jean michel
moi j'hésite alors on veut je me vois tu
voyais beaucoup tombent pas moi ça me
fait rire encore une fois c'est jean
michel c'est dans la caricature c'est un
livre on voit que c'est extrêmement
voilà c'est vraiment c'est de la blague
jean-michel on a beau se moquer de lui
fait du théâtre un machin il fait plein
de trucs
moi ça me fait rire c'est assez minable
de ramener ça à la seule vaut laisser la
chance au produit a été piqué avant
hockey dépannage ils sortiront jouant là
il m'a rien dit
cet ami qu'il écrivait au moins pour
ceux qui rament et de ce baiser sur le
singe c'est vraiment minable c'est ce
que c'est on en a parlé favre à la les
bref c'est pénible pour moi je voulais
c'est très drôle quand les ans vous êtes
marié rien qu'en dix ans le pitch
chabert c'est bon c'est bon si vous
n'aimez pas non le livre de jean michel
a deux défauts le premier c'est d'avoir
été écrit le deuxième c'est d'être
bientôt publié franchement je ne sais
pas comment vous pouvez rire moi je suis
outrée quand je vois ben je vous dis je
suis désolé j'ai pas trop sudoku ça ne
fait pas rire dans la période des 3
couture
ce que ça vous savez à bordeaux continue
avec junior moi je trouve qu'il faut
quand même voir un peu le livre pour en
parler ce fait désolé mais vous allez
rallumer honnêtement ces potaches j'ai
perçu à mort de rire en attaque qui
c'est vrai qu'à faire un sudoku français
je suis prête à tout en baissant il faut
un peu de défections un peu s'est vu
trop beau trop